- But do people still recognize
you from the voice of,
I mean, I feel like you're Dwight,
I feel like you can't go anywhere
and people still recognize.
- I will be Dwight to my grave.
- I will be the girl that
sings "Since U Been Gone."
So we're
- Yes.
- Here we go.
- You sang that?
- Yeah.
- I love that song.
- That's what I will be so.
- Well, you were also, Kelly Clarkson!
- Yes, that too.
Thank you, Steve Carell, yes, yes.
There's that as well?
Yeah.
- Yeah, what was the question?
- That's all I've done in my whole career.
- Yeah.
- That's what I would say.
Are you 'cause like, do you,
I heard that you tweeted this,
so let me show you what,
let me show everybody what you tweeted.
So you were "At dentist
office, put on a mask
because the woman next to me
has a Dunder Mifflin shirt on."
Which you have to be a hardcore fan.
I'm just saying.
- Yeah.
- To be wearing that shirt.
So one, did your root canal go well?
'Cause you were at the dentist.
And I heard it was a root canal, but two,
do you get nervous in that
situation 'cause you're trapped?
You're like trapped there.
So you can't be like
nice and then head off.
- Yeah, I was going in without a mask
and I saw her and her kid
and she had a Dunder Mifflin t-shirt
and so I was like, ooh,
this is so awkward.
I'm gonna have to sit for
15 minutes with this woman.
So I went and got a mask so.
- Or maybe longer in the waiting room.
- Maybe longer, so I went in incognito,
so we just didn't have to
have the awkward conversation.
But I appreciate the fans so much.
- But it's not about the
awkward conversation,
it's like, it's a fine conversation,
then it's awkward when it's just quiet
and you've talked about it
and you're just sitting
so closely together.
Yeah, that's the awkward part.
Where you're like, yeah,
we're just both here.
BJ Novak was recently at a bar
and a fan sent him Kelly
Kapoor's favorite drink.
- Yes.
- That drink is a seven and seven
with eight maraschino cherries,
sugar on the rim, blend it if you can.
Have you ever had one of these drinks?
- Okay, so this is from,
so I have never had one.
And this is from an episode of the office.
So Kelly Kapoor likes the
most sugary drink of all time.
- [Kelly] Which I am into.
It's a good thing her name is Kelly.
We'd get along.
- So it's like seven and seven.
It's like 7-Up and I don't
know what the other seven is.
- It's like Seagram's
Seven, is that what it is?
- Yeah, Seagram's Seven, seven and seven
with seven maraschino cherries.
It's like disgusting.
- Okay.
- But BJ got sent it and I've
never had it, but I've always,
it sounds disgusting, but
- Here's the thing
if it's disgusting, we're gonna find out
because I made them.
- Yes!
- Here we go.
Thank you, Justin.
- Oh my god, thank you.
Wait.
- Oh, wait.
I love, blended if you can.
- Oh my god, here, cheers.
- It is blended.
- Fully blended.
- Wait, the sugar on the rim.
- It's pink.
- That's a different pink.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna get some.
- Oh my God.
- Okay.
- Hmm. Just giving me diabetes.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God.
It's like straight up like a snow cone.
- This tastes delicious.
- It's like a snow cone.
- This is like something that
you would get, first of all,
feels like a child would like
to drink this, which is bad.
- My daughter's gonna
see this and be like,
"Why didn't you bring it home?"
- Why didn't you bring it home?
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is like something
they would have at Universal City Walk.
- And that I would definitely
get and say it's for my kids,
but really drink it myself.
What?
- This is awesome.
- No one does that.
- Thank you, Kelly for my
awesome seven and seven.
- Your first drink that's yours.
- Okay, so Meredith was
always flashing people
on "The Office," which is awesome.
How did your dad feel about that?
- My dad did not care for that.
- [Kelly] I imagine.
- I'm glad it was NBC and not HBO
'cause it was a better situation,
but he literally wrote me a
letter during first season
and it said, "Dear Kate,
stop taking off your shirt.
Love Dad."
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And there was a stamp of the Pope on it.
- I love that your dad,
did you say there was just
a stamp of the Pope on it?
(Kelly laughing)
So pray for yourself while you're.
But I love that your dad thought
that you came up with it.
Like, hey guys, I have this
great idea to do on the show.
- Hey!
- Did you?
- No.
- Oh I was like.
I was like, 'cause I hear like,
I'm just doing what it says.
- But if you really want me, no.
- But if you're really into
it and you want this shirt.
So you met your boyfriend on "The Office."
I know him.
So like, who made the first move?
- I invited him to my comedy act.
'Cause I, but I invited
all the guys in the crew.
Like I wasn't, I know right.
Come on, right.
It was just like, I don't know.
And then he asked me out
when he came to the show.
So like literally, we
are kind of Jim and Pam,
like 'cause we worked together.
And it took a while for,
I mean we didn't start dating
until the end of season two.
- Oh wow, so that's a lot of like
getting to know each other
without any pressure.
- He wasn't there every day,
but he's standing out in the
fake men's room off the kitchen
on the set of "The Office,"
you guys know where that is, right?
Anyway.
- No, I love that
you hung out with a guy that
hung out in a fake men's room.
That's awesome.
- My dad owns a bar.
I have a great life.
- Did you?
It's interesting.
I'm so stoked.
We're all stoked.
Everybody loves "The Office"
even 4,000 years later.
Like I feel
- Yeah.
- Is it it's kind of impressive though?
Like still, people are just
now 'cause of Netflix as well.
Like my son, he's 13 and
he just told me last week,
he's like gone through so many episodes.
He's going through the whole thing now.
He loves it.
- Yeah.
- It's like, bringing
a whole new life to it.
- You know we kind of
crush it at middle schools.
Like really, we do.
Like I was touring a middle
school and they were like,
can you not go in the classrooms?
'Cause the kids were like.
- They were distracted.
- Yeah, but middle schools.
- Yes.
- I feel like the show is in some ways,
even more popular than when it was on.
- Oh yeah.
- When it was airing live on NBC.
And I think it's because of streaming.
You can binge it.
You can watch it whenever you want now.
There's the internet.
- There's the internet.
- There was no Instagram when
we were filming "The Office."
- Yeah.
- Isn't that crazy to think.
I think about that with my career.
Like what has happened in the, you know,
the span of with social
media and everything.
- Yeah.
- That's insane, but it's
brought a whole new life to it.
It's such great writing, great characters.
It's just such a phenomenal thing.
So you started a new
podcast and basically,
tell everybody what your,
"Office Ladies" is the podcast,
but tell 'em what you do.
- All right.
- Okay, you go.
'Cause you're good at this part.
- All right.
Every week we watch an
episode of "The Office"
and then we break it down
and we tell you all of our
behind the scenes memories,
stories, and trivia,
everything we can remember.
We reach out to cast
members and crew members
and we give you all the scoop.
- All the scoop.
- We started from the
beginning with episode one
and we're going in order.
- All the way through.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
- But this week, your podcast,
the episode is about
the fire episode, right?
- Yes.
Oh that was a really fun one
because that was the
first episode that we shot
outside of the offices.
So we were, it was an exterior shoot.
The fire alarm goes off
and we all have to go
out to the parking lot.
And there was this, we're
gonna talk about this
on the podcast.
- I know, but I just
want you guys to notice,
do you see how Jenna is?
Here's the synopsis.
This is what happened.
- Yeah, I give some context.
- And then I'm like, that's
the one with the bug.
Remember the bug.
- It's so different, the personalities.
- A little bit.
- But so there was this giant
bug that started attacking us
and it was very large,
it was unusually large.
- Listen, it zeroed in on me.
I don't know why.
I think, I don't know.
Maybe 'cause I look less
threatening 'cause I'm short.
- 'Cause you're tinier.
- I'm tiny.
But it kept like buzzing my head.
I don't know about you.
I don't like anything by my ear.
Don't get by my ear because,
- Okay!
- There goes your social life.
There goes making out.
- Okay, all right.
There's one person who can get by my ear.
- No, I'm with you,
I've been on stage on
tour and they attack me
'cause I'm in a spotlight.
So if you're outside in a shed tour,
yeah, they just,
and there's these like
prehistoric ones down in Florida.
- That's what this was!
- Yes!
- It was from olden times.
- I was like is this a dinosaur?
- It was, yeah.
- Yeah.
- It was the size of a Buick.
It was like,
and I thought, we started doing a joke
that it was gonna like
pick me up and take me away
'cause it landed on my shoulder.
- Oh, I wish I could make that joke.
(Kelly laughing)
Things I'll never say.
No, but that's amazing.
- This bug.
- John Krasinski does great impressions.
- He does.
- People or things or whatever.
- He's amazing.
- He's an amazing impressionist.
So he started doing an
impression of Angela
being carried away by
the bug and it was like.
- It was like (buzzing)
And I'm like.
- It was so funny.
- Anyway, you guys, it was hilarious.
Make John Krasinski do the
giant bug thing for you
when you run into him.
- I will make him do it.
I'll get him on this show
and make him, demand it.
- Yes.
And then make him do his boom operator.
- He does a great
- Boom operator.
He does a great boom operator.
- And he does a great Muppet.
- [Kelly] Those are random gifts.
- Oh he does a really good Muppet.
- That's random talents.
I cannot wait to meet him.
- I know.
John right now is like, thanks ladies.
All my bits.
- You actually, you found
it was from your first table read, right?
You found a photo from
your first table read
that you all did.
- Oh yes, yes.
- Yes, our casting director, Allison Jones
brought her camera and
she took a Polaroid of us
and she gave one to each of us
and I saved mine all these years.
- That's so cool.
We do Polaroids on this show, I love it.
It just looks vintage and cool.
- I didn't get one 'cause
I wasn't there that day.
- She hadn't been cast yet.
- I hadn't been cast yet.
- Yeah.
- I'm okay with it.
- Wasn't it funny though?
Aren't you, Angela, you tried out right,
when everyone auditioned.
- I did.
- You auditioned for her part, right?
- I auditioned for the role of Pam
and I went in, you guys, and
I thought I did so great.
And it was a big room.
- You did, you got the
job, just a different one.
- Well, I got a different job,
but it was a room full of people.
And there's a moment where
Michael is fake firing Pam
in front of Ryan, the
temp, to like pull a prank
and Pam starts to cry
and calls him a jerk.
And I called him like a jerk
and everyone started laughing
and I was like,
I don't think that was
supposed to be a laugh.
I think I missed something.
And then of course you see this
vulnerable moment that Pam,
as much as she hates
that job, she needs it.
And Jenna did such an
amazing job portraying that.
But so, they said I didn't get the part
'cause I was a little too feisty.
Too feisty for Pam.
- You were raised in
Texas, so it's understood.
- I know, listen, I'll call someone a jerk
if they're a jerk.
- I'll call someone something else, yeah.
- [Angela] Maybe, yeah.
- It depends on the moment.
- But then they brought me back.
They said, hey, we've got
kind of a judgey snarky lady
in accounting.
I said, okay.
- That call's amazing.
Hey, you know what you'd be perfect for?
- A snarky lady.
- This snarky lady.
Okay, no, but have your
kids seen "The Office" yet?
Do they watch it right now?
- Mine have not.
I have an eight-year-old
and a five-year-old.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- And my kids hadn't seen it either.
Except this year, they're in fifth grade.
Two of them are in fifth grade
and all their friends
watched it over the summer.
And so my mom was like, I
mean, my daughter was like,
"Mom, can I please finally
watch "The Office?"
And I was like, okay.
And I was at the time watching
Healthcare for the podcast,
I was like, why don't
you watch Healthcare?
And she was like, "Mom,
what's an anal fissure?"
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God, I love this conversation.
- [Angela] And I was like, I was like.
- Is that when you say go ask your dad?
- Well no, I was like, it's a real.
And she goes, "Is that real?"
I was like, yes.
Fast forward.
So I don't know, so yeah.
She's watching "The Office" now.
It's not all anal fissures.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's not.
- So out of all, it's not.
So out of all the episodes,
what scene was for each of
you was the hardest to shoot?
- Oh.
- We were talking about this
because I mean there's hardest,
emotionally hardest because
we were laughing so hard.
So where should we start?
- I think our hardest because
we were laughing so hard
was the dinner party episode.
- Yeah, so hard.
- We just laughed our
way through that week
that we ruined so many takes,
the bunch of us on that.
But then hardest emotionally
was just the whole episode
where we were saying goodbye
to Steve.
- To Steve.
- When we sing to him,
when I had my, I mean,
we just were crying through everything.
And when I had my goodbye
to him at the airport,
that was really rough.
- Yeah, we were just so teary all week
and Will Ferrell was
a guest star that week
and I was standing next to him for a scene
and he goes "I feel like
I'm at like a funeral,
but I'm supposed to be
funny at the funeral."
- Oh my gosh.
- And I was like, oh,
that must be really hard.
- Yeah.
- To be around all of us.
But yeah, and then also like
there was awkward things
that were hard 'cause they were awkward.
Like I had to toss a cat into a ceiling.
- [Kelly] You really did
toss a cat like a real cat?
- [Angela] I mean look at that.
Oh no, it was, it was, it was all.
- I mean I remember the,
I thought maybe it was a fake cat.
- Oh well there was a--
- Parts of it were fake.
- Not, well, not part of the animal.
- No, but I mean parts of the
shot were with a fake cat.
- And yes.
But I had to like in the scene where
like everyone's going crazy
and like Kevin has a copier
and he's like, ah!
I had to like take a cat out of a drawer,
which I guess my character's
kept a cat in her drawer
all these years.
- So that's not creepy at all.
- That's not creepy.
And the cat is huge.
This wasn't like a little cat.
It was like enormous.
- Like a heifer.
- It was!
It was like a heifer.
Bless her heart.
- [Kelly] Bless her heart.
- Bless her heart, she's a heifer.
Anyway so I had to get this big cat
and then I had to like swing it
and do this whole thing.
- And you're little.
- And I'm little.
And it's like, (imitating meows)
it was like not into it.
And then everyone was screaming,
so that was difficult.
- Or awesome.
- [Angela] Or awesome, yeah.
- So "The Office" is coming
to the NBC streaming service right now.
So would you do a reboot?
Would y'all do it?
- We talk about this all the time.
We wanna do a reunion special,
like a reason that everyone in the office
has to reunite for some reason,
like a one time special episode.
- Like a movie.
Like a reunion movie.
Because I think a reboot would be hard.
I think it at the end of the series,
I mean spoiler alert
for anyone who's still
in the middle of it,
but some of the people
don't end up staying
at the paper company anymore.
- Yeah.
- They move on, they move away.
And so to manufacture some reason
why we're all working there
again, I think would be odd.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I think there is a reason
that we could all reunite
in some other way.
So that's what we're.
- We have some ideas.
- That's what we want, call us.
- Call us NBC, email us.
- I think it would be so good.
Like I said, like, it's
just got such a new life.
Like people are like a younger age
are getting into these characters.
It's really cool.
- And on a selfish level,
I would like to work with
all those people again.
I'd like to have us
all in a room together.
- Yes!
- It was such a great
chemistry, great vibe, yeah.
- I teared up when I got here
because your security guy,
Joseph outside did
security for "The Office"
for seven years.
We saw him every day.
- We gave Joseph a big hug.
- We gave him a big hug.
He used to help me when
my daughter came to set.
I had like a little, you
know, the little pink car
you push your kid around
in and it's really loud
it's like clack, clack, clack, clack.
- Yeah, and everyone loves you.
- Everyone loves you.
I would like push her around
and Joseph would like help me
take it out and set it out.
And he's just a sweetheart,
but I would love to see everyone again.
- It would be amazing.
- We might have to steal Joseph
for that week of shooting
if you don't mind.
- It's okay,
I'm okay with that.
- We wanna come back.
- Joseph can go, just so I can see it.
In "The Office" though,
your character punched a hole in the wall
and I wanted to ask you this, like,
'cause I've been able
to in a video of mine,
I think it was the "Since
U Been Gone" video,
I got to trash a room and they
said I could break a table
and it was a glass table.
And then I found out,
oh, it's sugar glass.
- Oh yeah.
- So it wasn't really like
breaking a real glass table.
It was like sugar glass,
but you feel powerful.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- Were you really punching the wall?
And did you break your knuckles?
- Here's the thing.
If you know me, you know
I'm an incredibly tough guy.
- Totally.
- So what I did is I told the stunt guys
make that wall extra thick
because I don't want it to be easy.
I want, (laughs)
this is so the opposite.
- [Kelly] I'm powerful.
- This is so the opposite.
No, I was literally like, guys,
we're gonna have to do
a lot of takes of this.
So just make sure it's
like basically paper thin.
- Yeah.
- And even still, the stunt guys,
like when you do something
like that, I mean,
I wouldn't have thought
that's a stunt, but it is.
The stunt coordinators come in.
They're like, okay, here's how,
we're gonna rehearse it slow.
They put a pad behind the
wall, it's a whole thing.
- Yeah.
- And thankfully I got
through multiple takes
with no serious injuries, but Kelly,
I did get some scratches on my knuckles.
And you know, I was cool about
it, but I got some scratches.
I'm just saying.
- I love it.
I freaked out.
I actually, I love the fact
that I got to trash a room,
but then I was kinda like
you're trashing a room.
I don't know.
It's everything you've been told not to do
like when you're kid, so you're like,
I can't imagine that like,
is this gonna hurt the first
punch you did into the wall?
- Yeah.
- No, thank you.